veamos cómo identificar al agente
reductor y al agente oxidante en una
reacción redox por aquí estamos formando
cloruro de sodio a partir de sodio
metálico y cloro en forma de gas y bueno
antes de empezar a asignar cuál es el
agente reductor y cuál es el agente
oxidante tenemos que asignarles estados
de oxidación
a todas estas moléculas así es que vamos
a empezar por el estado de oxidación del
sodio ahora los átomos de sodio son
átomos que están en su forma elemental y
por lo tanto tienen un estado de
oxidación cero para el cloro cada uno de
estos dos átomos se encuentra en su
forma elemental cada átomo de cloro
tiene un estado de oxidación cero y por
lo tanto cada átomo tiene un estado de
oxidación cero bueno ahora vamos a la
derecha queremos saber cuál es el estado
de oxidación de éste catión de sodio el
catch ión de sodio tiene una carga
positiva + 1
para iones mono atómicos como este
cloruro de sodio el estado de oxidación
es igual a la carga de lyon y por lo
tanto como la carga de este camión de
sodio es más 1 entonces su estado de
oxidación es más 1 y bueno por aquí para
el cloruro este también es un ión mono
atómico pero ahora con carga menos 1 por
lo tanto su estado de oxidación es menos
bueno ahora pensemos qué es lo que
sucedió en esta reacción redox y vamos a
empezar por el sodio el sodio pasó de un
estado de oxidación cero a un estado de
oxidación más 1 eso es un incremento en
el estado de oxidación y entonces por
definición el sodio está siendo oxidado
y el sodio está siendo oxidado por otro
lado el cloro pasa de un estado de
oxidación cero a un estado de oxidación
-1 lo que hay se reduce su estado de
oxidación y por lo tanto cada átomo de
cloro está siendo reducido pero bueno
antes de empezar a asignar cuál es el
agente reductor y cuál es el agente
oxidante veamos otra vez
esta reacción pero ahora observando los
electrones de valencia de cada uno de
estos átomos ok lo tenemos por aquí y
bueno ahora también vamos a utilizar
este método para determinar el estado de
oxidación de estos átomos
empecemos por asignarle un estado de
oxidación a este átomo de sodio si aquí
representamos a los electrones de
valencia por estos puntitos podemos
encontrar el estado de oxidación de un
átomo pensando en la cantidad de
electrones de valencia que normalmente
tiene ese átomo y restándole la cantidad
de electrones de valencia que tienen
estos átomos en estas condiciones no
creo entonces saber el sodio pertenece
al grupo 1 y por lo tanto generalmente
tiene un electrón de valencia a su
alrededor y por aquí podemos observar
que el sodio tiene un electrón de
valencia en este dibujo entonces tenemos
que restar 1 por lo que el estado de
oxidación de este sodio es 1 menos uno o
sea cero que bueno es exactamente lo
mismo que teníamos por aquí así es que
el sodio tiene un estado de oxidación
cero
y observa que tenemos dos moléculas de
sodio por aquí y eso lo estamos
representando en esta ecuación por este
2 de aquí bueno y ahora asignemos le un
estado de oxidación a cada uno de los
átomos de cloro en esta molécula de
cloro ok ahora estos claros tienen aquí
un enlace que está compuesto por dos
electrones cuando estamos asignando
estados de oxidación generalmente le
asignamos ambos electrones a el átomo
más electrón negativo del enlace sin
embargo en este caso tenemos exactamente
el mismo elemento y por lo tanto no hay
diferencia de electro negatividad y lo
que hacemos es asignarle un electrón a
cada uno de los átomos
sí y a la hora de encontrar el estado de
oxidación de este átomo el cloro
generalmente tiene 7 electrones de
valencia a su alrededor y como podemos
observar en este diagrama de puntos
el cloro tiene 7 electrones de valencia
a su alrededor
entonces restamos 7 y 77 es 0 así es que
el estado de oxidación de cada uno de
estos átomos de cloro es 0 lo cual
concuerda con lo que tenemos por aquí y
bueno este es el estado de oxidación
también para este otro átomo de cloro
pero bueno aquí tenemos dos formas
distintas de encontrar los estados de
oxidación de los átomos esta es una
forma que requiere más memorización esta
es un poquito más enredosa pero a veces
sirve mucho ver los electrones por aquí
bueno vamos a los productos en el
producto tenemos dos moléculas de
cloruro de sodio aunque ellos están por
aquí este es un cloruro de sodio y
este es el segundo cloruro de sodio y
ahora pongamos mucha atención en qué
sucedió con los electrones gray este
electrón de este átomo de sodio fue
agregado a este átomo de cloro y lo
mismo sucedió con este electrón del
sodio fue a dar a otro átomo de cloro
cada átomo de sodio perdió su electrón
de valencia formando un camión de sodio
con una carga positiva y bueno para
calcular el estado de oxidación de los
productos hacemos lo mismo el sodio
generalmente tiene un electrón de
valencia pero justo como perdió ese
electrón de valencia ahora no tiene
ningún electrón de valencia y por lo
tanto su estado de oxidación es más uno
que como lo habíamos visto por aquí y
hacemos lo mismo para el año en cloruro
porque generalmente el cloro tiene 7
electrones de valencia pero se quedó con
este electrón morado lo que por lo tanto
ahora
tiene 8 electrones de valencia y
entonces su estado de oxidación es menos
1 que como tenemos por aquí y bueno tal
vez viendo todo este proceso ahora tiene
más sentido el porque el estado de
oxidación de iones mono atómicos es
igual a su carga pero bueno ya que vimos
todo este proceso y entendemos qué es lo
que está pasando con los electrones
escribamos algunas de mis reacciones y
ahora sí hablemos de cuál es el agente
reductor y cuál es el agente oxidante
que vamos a partir la reacción un
poquito más partirla en pedazos para
entenderla mejor todavía vamos a empezar
con el sodio ok podemos ver por aquí que
tenemos dos átomos de sodio dos átomos
de sodio que se transforman en dos
cationes de sodio
se transforman en dos cationes de sodio
ahora para transformarse de sodio a un
camión de sodio estos átomos perdieron
sus electrones de valencia a morados ok
cada uno de estos átomos perdió un
electrón que voy a poner por aquí grade
2 electrones y esta es la reacción
parcial de oxidación o también conocida
como semi reacción de oxidación porque
nuestros átomos están perdiendo
electrones ok y sabemos que la pérdida
de electrones es oxidación así es que
esta es la reacción parcial de oxidación
por otro lado también tenemos la
reacción parcial de reducción en la que
tenemos una molécula de cloro pero cada
uno de estos átomos de cloro se queda
con uno de estos electrones y se
transforma en una unión cloruro entonces
tenemos nuestra molécula de cloro
los claros se quedan con dos electrones
estos mismos dos electrones que están
perdiendo los átomos de sodio y se
transforma en dos camiones cloruro y
esta molécula de cloro
con estos dos electrones se transforma
en dos uniones cloruro que es lo que
tenemos escrito por aquí ahora estos
electrones están del lado de los
reactivos entonces en esta reacción
parcial estamos ganando electrones y por
lo tanto se trata de una semi reacción
de reducción porque la ganancia de
electrones es reducción y bueno si
juntamos a estas dos reacciones
parciales vamos a obtener la reacción
redox original
ok porque estos electrones se van a
cancelar ok porque de hecho estos
electrones son exactamente los mismos
estos 2 electrones que pierden los
átomos de sodio
exactamente los mismos electrones que
ganan los átomos de cloro y eso es justo
lo que estábamos viendo por aquí aunque
ahí el sodio pierde dos electrones que
van a dar al cloro entonces cuando
juntamos nuestros reactivos nos quedan
dos átomos de sodio y una molécula de
cloro y en los productos tenemos dos en
a se l
aquí tenemos dos n
cl que es por supuesto nuestra ecuación
original balanceada redox y ahora sí ya
estamos listos para determinar cuál es
el agente reductor y cuál es el agente
de oxidación
el chiste para no confundirse es pensar
en todos estos electrones y qué están
haciendo y saber muy bien cuál es la
definición de estos términos porque para
no confundirnos el sodio está siendo
oxidado y en su oxidación está aportando
los 12
drones que necesita el cloro para ser
reducido por lo tanto el sodio es el
agente que permite que el cloro sea
reducido o dicho de otra forma
sodio es el agente reductor ok porque
está haciendo que el cloro se reduzca
aunque en ese mismo proceso el sodio
esté siendo oxidado aquí vamos a
anotarlo por aquí el sodio es el agente
reductor que permite que el cloro se
reduzca el sodio a la hora de ser
oxidado aporta los electrones necesarios
para reducir al cloro y por lo tanto es
el agente reductor del cloro por otro
lado el cloro está aceptando dos
electrones y por lo tanto está siendo
reducido pero el hecho de que el cloro
acepte esos dos electrones hace que el
sodio se oxide entonces el cloro es el
agente oxidante del sodio
y el cloro es el agente oxidante y bueno
esto es algo que confunde muchas veces a
los estudiantes la diferencia entre ser
oxidado y reducido y ser el agente
reductor o el agente oxidante ok pero el
sodio puede estar siendo oxidado y ser
un agente reductor de hecho van de la
mano si un átomo pierde electrones
entonces está siendo oxidado y como esos
electrones van a ir a reducir a otro
elemento entonces también es un agente
reductor y bueno al mismo tiempo el
cloro está siendo reducido está
aceptando estos electrones y por lo
tanto está oxidando al sodio ok entonces
como el cloro está oxidando al sodio
el agente oxidante así es que lo primero
que tienes que hacer es asignar los
estados de oxidación pensar muy bien en
estas definiciones y entonces si ya
puedes asignar cuál es el agente
oxidante y cuál es el agente reductor